I heard a piece of content from Gary
that I really liked I'm pissed he said
it cuz it's really good he said dude the
niche is you you're the niche like look
at Rogan Rogan wasn't like oh you know
I'm going to toss in some comedy I'm
going toss in some fighting stuff and
then like shrooms and then aliens and
then politics a little bit he just
with that stuff and so that's what he
talks about I actually really like
philosophy I like comedy I like
marketing and sales I like business
stuff and that's what my content's about
how do you recreate that get interested
in stuff do things and then talk about
the stuff that you did and you probably
do have a few completely disjointed
things that you're into it's the combo
of five things in different proportions
that then creates the thumb print that
makes the Creator unique